- [Mark] All right, Math, Math.
Where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- [Math] I'm from La
Crescenta, California.
It's at the top of the 2 freeway.
- [Mark] A suburb of LA?
- Yeah.
It's what's called a
census-designated place.
They found that there was a place there
when they did the census.
It's not part of a town or a city.
It's part of the county unincorporated.
But they didn't notice it
until they did the census.
I read this on Wikipedia.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
You had both your parents as a kid?
- I don't like the people who
raised me, either one of them.
And I recently learned that I was adopted.
So they're not my parents.
I had a kind of miserable
time but it was a while ago.
(chuckling) I had a kind of miserable time
but it was a while ago, yeah.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
Was there abuse or anything like that?
- It was really boring.
I wasn't allowed to go out
enough, have enough friends.
I spent all my free time doing homework.
Basically doing homework
and sometimes watching TV.
They were very against me going out with
other kids my age and
partying or whatever.
Very against drugs, very against dating,
very against driving.
So, I don't know, it sucked.
- [Mark] So you went out
on your own at what age?
- I lived there until I went to college
and I went to college when I was 17.
I went to University
of Southern California.
- You went to USC?
- Mm-hmm.
Good for you.
So you were a good student?
- Yeah, I was a good student.
- [Mark] And you went on
your own after school?
- Went on my own after school.
What do you mean?
- [Mark] What did you
do after you graduated?
- After I graduated, then I
got a master's in New York.
And then I,
what did I do after?
I learned to dance, finally.
I stopped talking to them,
the people that raised me.
I learned to do drugs, learned to dance,
learned to date, sort of.
Had a long relationship with a boy.
With a guy.
His name is Steven.
Oh, yeah, we had a band together.
It was called Belt.
- [Mark] Guys are your preference?
- Guys are my preference.
I'm into, do you know
who David Griffith is?
I'm really into him.
He's in Driving Miss Daisy.
I think he calls himself a man, not a guy.
What does he call himself?
An actor?
Oh, yeah, a really old drunk guy.
Okay, he calls himself a guy, nevermind.
Yeah, guys are my preference.
I'm not into girls sexually
but I like girls, of course.
- [Mark] And you were born a female?
- Mm-hmm, yeah.
- Yeah.
You've worked, you've had jobs?
- Oh, yeah, I've had jobs.
I was a host at a Sushi
and Shabu shabu restaurant.
I was a editor of other people's
graduate school admissions essays.
I was a
retail employee at American Apparel.
And I was a person who let
you in, front desk person,
at a bath house in San
Francisco called Eros.
- [Mark] So drugs came
into your life at what age?
- Drugs came into my life at what age.
I think I was pretty young
the first time I had a drug.
But I didn't start to do drugs
until I was in college, basically.
I wish I had been able to
do more of them earlier.
But the people who raised me,
my mom and dad and also my sister
are all very
scared of drugs.
Although, they do them, kind of.
Kind of, not really, but kind of.
Me, I love drugs.
- [Mark] What is your drug?
- My favorites are methamphetamine,
cannabis, marijuana, and LSD.
I also really MDA and MDMA.
- [Mark] And how do you
support yourself now?
I've heard everything so
you can tell me whatever.
- I want to make a feature film.
I think Disney, the studio,
is going to help me make a feature film.
Other things I know how
to do are be a cashier
and be the singer in a band
and go to the EBT office.
- [Mark] Where are you staying now?
- Right now, I'm staying,
I'm not sure the address, actually.
- [Mark] But you're on the street?
- Have been for almost two years.
- [Mark] Two years.
And how is that experience,
how has that been for you?
- Shitty, of course, boring, mostly.
I've had a lot of trouble accessing
accurate information about
basic things involving housing.
A housing office that isn't closed.
Meeting a realtor that
actually gives you the place
to live and doesn't themselves,
somehow, use it instead.
Partly because one of
the people who raised me
was a realtor who was either trained wrong
or unethical, or whatever.
That's part of the reason
I have that problem.
I'm in the wrong tradition of it.
I'm in the misinformation tradition of it.
Also, I've noticed this is a
huge problem for many people
in America, accessing
information about housing.
I'm sure you've noticed a
lot of people live in tents
and probably don't want to.
Sorry, (chuckling) I know that's boring.
- [Mark] That's all right.
You still have contact
with your family, or no?
- I don't consider my family
the people that raised me.
And I don't want to be in touch with them.
And mostly, I'm not.
One of them recently filed
a missing person's report about me.
And I think I was able to
address it and let them know
that I'm alive and that I
don't have to talk to them.
Nobody has to like anybody, et cetera.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- I'm 40.
I turned 40 in June.
- [Mark] You're 40?
Have you been in love before?
- [Math] Yeah, I've been
in love before, yeah.
Have you?
- I have.
Great experience until it's not.
- [Math] (chuckling) Great
experience until it's not.
- [Mark] But you've
had good relationships?
- [Math] Um, good relationships, yeah.
Since I've been homeless, I
haven't had a phone or laptop,
in almost two years, to
express myself to people.
Although, of course,
there's always talking.
I'm like, oh, I want
to check and make sure
my conversations are good but I think so.
I think I've had some really, really good
and deep relationships, not necessarily
that I even liked all of those people.
- Do you have friends?
- Yeah.
I have friends.
I need to meet more of them in person.
But I've done this type of thing before.
Find someone really cool on Facebook
and buy them a plane
ticket to come visit me
and befriend them in person.
And then say, okay, well,
see you again, sometime.
I wish I was in a situation where I saw
my friends more often
or more on the computer.
More on the computer
and then also in person.
But I have friends, yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have emotions
that you've struggled with
more often than others?
Depression, or anxiety, or
anger, anything like that?
- I have struggle expressing
myself emotionally,
or getting emotional,
especially without having a place to stay.
It's hard to break down
on the bus, or whatever,
really let go on the bus.
Sometimes I'm too much of a
show off for the computer.
If that makes sense.
There's an artificial intelligence.
Not an artificial intelligence, sorry,
but there's an intelligence
related to technology
or the computer and I'm like,
blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
Check me out, check me out.
Like, hi, camera, I'm saying
hi to you, the camera,
separately from saying
hi to the photographer
and separately from
saying to everything else.
Check me out.
And so I'm expressing
something to the camera
and ignoring the person.
So whatever kind of emotion that is.
There must be a word for this, I guess.
Maybe I have a syndrome
that FUCO doesn't know about.
- [Mark] Have you been treated
for mental conditions before?
- Yeah, I love drugs.
- [Mark] What are you
proudest of in your life?
- How good I am at naming
things, titling things.
My favorite memory is
something with the person
who lived across the street from me
when I was growing up on
Raymond Ave in La Crescenta,
something with this
person, David Griffith.
I'm not sure which part
of which part I mean.
One time, I got to sleep over at his house
and I was waking up in his house
and I was disoriented for a minute.
Where am I?
Oh, yeah, I'm in that guy's house.
Oh, yeah, yeah, wow,
cool, I'm in his house.
Maybe that.
And yeah, I'm really
good at titling things.
One of my favorite things that
I've done in naming things
is I have a song called Limelight.
And it's about Simba and
Nala from the Lion King.
And also it's about two phones
that got stolen from me.
- [Mark] How did you end up homeless?
- I stopped being, it's
complicated and kind of boring.
They weren't supposed to
be charging rent at all,
the people who were charging
rent, it wasn't their house.
I stopped being able to
afford it and I was evicted.
- [Mark] What's the most-important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- The most important lesson
I've learned in my life is,
the zodiac, the sign, gemini,
cancer, leo, et cetera,
is real, actually.
For a long time, I dismissed it as,
or not dismissed it exactly
but didn't care about it
and it's really important
to understanding people
and understanding
animals, I guess.
The signs are named after animals, mostly.
Understanding sexuality, I don't think so.
Really important to understanding people
and understanding racing, or something.
- [Mark] Have you ever asked your parents
how you got the name Math?
- They didn't name me that.
When I was growing up,
my name was Laura Snyder,
Laura Holly Snyder.
And I changed my name
to Math in 2001 or 2002.
And then, in 2013, I made it legal.
I went to a courthouse in
Oakland and changed it there
and got it on my ID and stuff.
- [Mark] Yeah, I saw it on your ID.
Why did you choose the name Math?
- Math tenure means the Big Dipper.
Sorry (chuckling).
Why did I choose the name Math.
I'm good with numbers.
I wanted something more androgynous.
I got this idea to have a dog
named Math or a cat named Math
because it's such a cool idea
to have a pet named Math.
- [Mark] Yeah, Math is
an interesting name.
- There's Math running around
in your kitchen, or whatever.
Math wants something.
And I thought about it for
a little while and decided,
yeah, I want it as my own
name, even though it's cooler
if it's a cat or a dog's name,
I like it as my own name.
And I don't really have pets.
- [Mark] Your androgyny is
something that you play up?
- Oh, sorry.
I'll try not to do that (chuckling).
- [Mark] Your androgyny is
something that you play up?
- I'm having trouble
thinking of the reference
but I love David Bowie.
That's a quote from a
Bowie interview, right?
- [Mark] I'm just asking you a question.
- My androgyny is something
that I play up, or--
- Cultivate?
- Cultivate.
- [Mark] Comes to you naturally?
- Me, I don't think about it that much.
My pronoun is he, but whatever.
Oh, sorry, my pronoun is he,
but it's not a big deal, I swear.
Androgyny is something I play up.
I don't want to get defensive.
I assume you're letting me know
that it is something I play up even though
it isn't something I thought I played up.
- [Mark] Well, you have
a beard and sideburns.
- Oh, yeah, I do take testosterone.
It's been a while since
I had a fresh vial.
Oh, I see what you mean.
Yes.
- [Mark] (chuckling)
Okay, we got an answer.
- I take testosterone.
- [Mark] Do you prefer being,
would you prefer to be considered a male?
- I get a huge thrill
out of being called he.
But also, I--
- When I met you, it was unclear
whether you were male or female.
- Yeah, I'm not trying to do that
but I don't want to
think about it that much.
How someone sees me, it's
fine if they see me as a girl.
Of course, it's fine (chuckling).
I get a huge thrill out of
it when they see me as a guy.
Am I ever really trying to do something
where it's confusing
if I'm a girl or a guy?
I guess.
Anyway, I don't mind
when people ask about it.
- [Mark] We're all free
to be who we should be.
Who we wanna be, right?
- Yeah, (chuckling) yeah.
Sometimes I say that being
a girl is the worst thing
I can think of and I'm exaggerating.
It's not, well, it is the worst thing
I can think of, for some reason.
It's the worst thing
I want to think about.
I don't want to think about murder, or--
- [Mark] You think being a woman is--
- Well, I'm sort of joking.
If you're a girl and you're a
girl and you like being a girl
then I don't have any
idea what that's like.
Being a girl, I say this all
the time, sort of as a joke,
being a girl is the worst
thing I can think of.
It's not the worst thing I can think of
but it's the worst thing I
can comfortably think about.
- [Mark] Are you happy?
Would you describe yourself as happy?
- I'm in a good mood
almost all the time but
I'm kind of miserable.
I need a computer and a
phone and a place to live.
But I'll have them soon.
I'm in a pretty good
mood almost all the time.
Always have been.
I don't get depressed hardly ever.
- [Mark] That's a good thing.
- Yeah, so only comparatively.
Depressed compared to how I
was last year, or whatever.
But compared to people who
actually have depressions,
I don't really get those.
I have
extremely good mental health or I have a
syndrome that hasn't been named yet
that has to do with trying
to impress the cartoon,
or whatever, more than I try
to connect with a person.
- [Mark] Okay (chuckling).
All right, Math, thank you
very much for talking with me.
And I wish you best of luck out there.
Be careful.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Mark] The streets are dangerous.
- Yeah, I know what you mean.
- [Mark] All right, thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- You're interesting.
- Thank you.